o youtube e o lado pessoal daqui quem
fala é o dar que sejam muito em 2011 é
mais um vídeo e o estrago de que o
segundo episódio the five nights é
fredes e sim pessoal eu vou fazer uma
série porque ontem um vídeo foi tão bem
recebido e o feedback foi tão bom que eu
só vi então comprar um jogo porque eu
tava só jogar uma delas não é então eu
só de comprar o jogo e fazer então as
noites todas e nós vamos então para a
segunda noite por lá pessoal para lá e
por que não consegue atender o telefone
ontem era que a ms aqui pronto lá senhor
é muito calma prontos ao cala é ok
pessoal vamos lá então ver as nossas
câmeras que está tudo bem calma
ontem o padre estava aqui ontem o padre
estava que eu acho
não me digam que eu só dei um salto de
um irmão já aqui o pato só luís começa
amanhã em de meia-noite
está aqui o pato ok isto começa a cair
só eu vou que ficar um pouco áspera que
a previsão saiu lhe hockey deixe-me que
ver se tem tem alguém na porta não tá
tranquilo eu acho que estou nem se vai
ser tranquilo
ok o país ainda está aqui cai esta
câmara continua sem sem imagem apenas
tem áudio aac o pé do meu quarto do time
ver se alguma coisa não tá tranquilo
o pato no ataque o pato que o padre
ouvir uma voz estranha
ainda que não é tanto de voz calma era
da wii avós vender que traz andar e
baixa trás da cortina meu é o quarto
ataque acho que os seguros rumo ao seu
perfil e nené quando eu estava no qatar
onde é que está o coelho o de tom coelho
o coelho com hélio coelho de cantar e
ouvir o som vem daí metalcore o
passo-a-passo também nené focar só se um
dos que dizem por ser um personagem que
proporciona kallstrom aqui eu sou aqui
estou aqui não aqui é uma questão
pessoal e não vai jogar os dois ouviram
um barulho eu estou mexer em qualquer
coisa meu da questão já não os vejo eu
já não vejo que está aqui o coelho
qualquer coisa aqui está na câmera 5 o
que agora quer segunda etapa pato o seu
patrão deputados
pato é calculado o outro ainda está
livre tal fato a taxa só não sei e não
ser perfeito pato mesmo aqui aqui eu
acho que não é nada o fundo acho que no
fundo é outro de tal e estes emanuel tac
também eu perdi completamente o pato meu
onde é que andou forte impacto ambiental
pato mel
calma calma calma ursi metal e rock
tranquilo zé manel puxa mas não estava
aqui por ser verdade estava no seu mané
lutava há uma semana ela na canção notou
a perda do meu quarto acreditar que um
tac está na câmara dois não querem o
pato meu eu já até passou muito tempo
ok do com 64% pátria e ainda é bom
pato por favor me cutucar as manel todos
com o mesmo fim
só quem está aqui
nunca fala pessoal vamos ficar aqui com
a minha espera ocupar também aí tá
tranquilo está tranquilo tranquilo
tranquilo por agora é negociar um ai ai
não essa câmera desaparecer com calma eu
prefiro esta câmara do porto esta câmera
em seu saque e ataque eo ataque o
carioca de tokyo sexwale ataque ocorre
agora no natal passado o país apareceu
completamente já há muito tempo eu não
sei nada deu ainda continuará disponível
pela praga uma câmera ela pagou uma
câmara
são três da manhã o seu domingo no sul
do rio do litoral sul teve quando eu
voltar eu caí foi com a cor outra vez
caíram de tal fato natal pato pato
anotar sua imagem e está aqui tá que o
path of pessoal locais já houve ataque o
pé das saladas pizzas a qualquer e ele
ainda está longe então o que é bom o que
é muito bom
ok ainda está aqui e se a maneira
daquela agora já saiu do culto eo ataque
o time perto de mim eu também penso em
mim porque eu já falei meu carro
ainda bem que o vista a bíblia ou cair
ainda está aqui não eu já sei o que a
senhora quer posso fechar a porta abre
pronto boa boa na boa e já ficava nisto
sol
agora é preciso saber de cantar eo
ataque não está aqui ok multa outros
emanuel calma calma estão silva ao i
hoje terá o que já estava ali dentro o
cajá no youtube nada a outro de manelão
evento meu mundo não vai ter sempre o
pai bs natalie o pato
aí aqui não há nada aqui também não só
apenas temos 27% bateria espero
conseguir resistir até o fim de semana
ela ainda está aqui o problema por uma
quebra com uma câmera vai conectar a
outro ato de apagar tudo apagar tudo
apagado o
tudo apagado ok vamos lá ver isto nada
nada
na imagem uma imagem nenhuma lei foi
shipp porque alguma coisa não estava
andando em campo
eu acho que na itália sombra de uma luz
eu não vou abrir a porta e detalhes
sombra dela ainda destaque o espanto com
a mãe
estes já sei já jack sock qualquer forma
nós temos que ter atenção a esse papel
atenção este pato quem mandar que tem
18% poderia destacar o pessoal está
muito bom tá muito ou mesmo empatar aqui
pataky e itaqui última semana e já tô
aqui hoje onde está ou estava aqui ok
pauli também a porta do táxi na noite da
quinta turma a pagar até final não letal
ou tribunal militar que baniu não sei
fazer o que meu ok assim também é
pessoal mas estamos quase na porta e não
está inerte
foi a meu eu não sai da porta e neuton
dos principais seria o símbolo perder 15
primeiro o gado sinta manhã falar falar
que aguenta aguentar que tomou não sei
se quisesse poderia o tamanho vai
apanhar foi apanhar aqui vai apanhar
aqui vai apanhar aqui
i o d'ale está livre
o caminho
eu tenho tentado encantar com esta
música ao cair 6 da manhã
será que eu consegui passar a noite eu
acho que sim porque os links que e hoje
pessoal eu vou estar um bonde este
episódio não vai ser só segunda noite
mas vai ser também a terceira noite por
isso deixem mesmo um forte apoio pessoal
e para lá então tentar passar à terceira
noite eu estar aqui
os outros dois ainda estão aqui então é
tranquilo ok pessoal deixe só confirmar
as câmeras todas é tranquilo você agora
um caminho a uma a taxa passa de espanha
pretende recusar mesmo dia às câmaras
manhã três cruzamentos das câmeras e as
luzes já está a usar as luzes
a partir daqui já apareceu aqui comprar
não digam que eu já está perto do
quartel
ayew salientou o piloto viu a falar em
cima do ps é pisar na época geisa ok ok
vamos parar um pouco pessoal vamos pra
um pouquinho enquanto evento e nos
fresca não é que é sempre bom é só o
pato lá seguiu para pinhais bull pessoal
e eu talvez a melhor o talento calma eu
vou fechar a porta é eu vou manter a
porta fechada até a ser embora aí sai
daqui pato é muito clipe
aí pronto assim eu vou abrir a porta
agora a holanda empatou na irlanda tal
ataque e saque até proteus a longe de
mim o que importa é o que importa e
vamos ficar aqui à espera mais um
pouquinho só fala sério vocês nem sabem
votar condá e ouvir aqui agora ao lado
de ligar a minha pintura é que tá muito
calor e ainda por cima tentar olhar para
este evento em a funcionar e não vai com
aron não é
mas pronto eu vou tentar aguentar o
pessoal vou tentar aguentar este calor
insuportável que está aqui e
resistiram este picchu criado já circula
em cima da silva sim na irlanda outro
país eu fui calma que carrie a estranha
aí será que os dentes
eu acho um erro patah
eu já perdeu patriota eu não sei se é o
pato é o dos dentes
não sei se já fez em três de que isto é
meu vou ver como querem d'água pessoal
assim sim se já gostou
assim a costa rica causando lhe um toque
eo toque meu então tô aqui meu olhar pra
mim talvez uma estourar né estourar
maléfico vez como chegou perto mas eu
não pode não pode não pode
léo não pode não pode
não pode o meu coração não pode isso
o meu coração e saltando sola seu jato
sem contatar gera esta séria eu bebo
raimi tudo sem um apoio do tamanho de um
tronco do meu xará indignada toma cru
featuring choro muito inchado e fica aí
bater na porta e cair
a senhora já foi embora já se foi embora
né pessoal agora agora foi bom só agora
foi muito bom pra mim tu festa só voltar
outra vez então fica aí não fica ruim
já o psd só uma de manhã uma também é eu
já vim atrás tremeu como é possível este
jogo é muito bizarro uma porta e outro
na outra eu estava em trabalho mas não
gostar ou não gostar de me tirar as
plantas físicas em que é o sistema em
pena de mim
meu nome é isso que eu quero só você
estiver mole este jogo é domingo é que
acontece tudo acontece do deus pois é um
jogo é pai não espera da instituição
está aqui ok apanham tão comissões não
foi keirrison e tem como aguentar aqui a
raiva com isso tudo aí está aqui outra
vez
josé pinto amarelo eu já sei o que
estive aqui
esperei quatro não vá pra aquela porta
outra vez não está aqui isso se alinha
ao que interessa
kaká eu vou cantar a empresa não ter
medo do colégio é o coelho é o bacharel
em tudo atrás num é tudo atrás num tudo
atrás
vocês viram isto não é isto
é só você e não da auto comendo muito
muito minha história bizarra só é
bizarro e pizarro a cabeza realizar a
realizar revisar o uso do jogo muito
muito muito
quando comecei a ter mérito eu canto
tóquio fechou a porta do meu fígado
zé manel o clube viu o dinheiro não está
a cantar meu também
a linha amarela está a cantar meu houve
naquela tarde
eu só queria lhe ok tá que o carro algum
curso ou este ataque está em cima eu
sair eu sexual vai saltar em cima tá em
cima tentar a tentar agora vou tentar
até agora a porta
ok eu acho que o osmar é o time pisar
agora vejo que está aqui ao tentar
tentou acordou e viu casa pretende
fechar a porta logo sabido
na quarta também é só quatro também é eu
tenho que aguentar isto tem e quando a
multa corresponde a porta mesmo é que
nem tem 16 vezes e estou no curso do sul
maior no ataque em que o papa se também
é falar para a platéia bastante espaço à
páscoa passada essa paz a paz a nossa
parte nenhuma
o nome que eu consegui passar a terceira
noite meu a sério pessoal rio pelo
afiado e nunca a sério não da quarta
noite pessoal
nós vamos ficar por aqui com este com
estes dois episódios só fala sério
deixem o vosso forte apoio neste vídeo
porque a série psicólogo raimi
completamente todo suor frio para a ep
eo pelo tudo em casa alguma coisa
pessoal por isso deixou sua equipe
favorita porém mesmo este vídeo e fiquem
bem e até amanhã à noite
o